Welcome back to recitation.
In this video, I'd like us to
work on an example of something
you actually saw in one
of the lecture videos,
and that's about
reduction formulas.
So what I'd like us to
do is to find a reduction
formula for the integral of
sine to the n x dx, which
I'm denoting by F sub n of x.
That's actually, F sub n
of x denotes the integral
of sine x raised to the n dx.
So the object here,
just to remind you
of what we'd like
to do, is to be
able to write F sub
n of x in a form
where maybe it involves
some functions,
but any integral
that it involves
is an integral of sine
to a lower power than n.
So an integral of sine x
So that's the object.
The object is to write
this down in such a way
that this integral is equal
to some functions maybe,
product of some functions,
added to another function that's
like F, but with
a lower subscript.
So I'm going to give you a
little time to work on it.
Why don't you pause the video,
take some time to work on it,
and when I come back,
I'll show you how I do it.
OK.
Welcome back.
Well, hopefully you were
able to make some headway
on this problem.
So let's take a look again
at what we want to do,
what the goal is, and then
we'll figure out a good strategy
to do that.
So the goal is to be able to
write F sub n of x as something
that involves a lower
numbered subscript than n.
Right?
So we'd like to be able to
take this integral, that's
a power of sine x, and
reduce the number of powers.
You know, it would be great
if we could just write down
a final formula, but
if we're able to reduce
the power of sine x, then we're
able to head in a direction
where we could
start to write down,
start to write this
down as functions
that don't involve integrals.
So the first step in
these kinds of things
is finding a reduction formula.
So a couple of things
I want to remind us.
We're going to make
the common substitution
that we make for powers of
sine or powers of cosine
that we see a lot.
Well, I guess,
actually there's two.
When you just see
a sine squared,
sometimes you do this half
angle formula, or double angle
formula, that Joel has
mentioned in some videos.
But in this one, we're more
interested in manipulating
the identity sine squared x plus
cosine squared x equals one.
In particular, we're going to
replace one of the sine squared
x's, or we're going to
replace two of the sines
by 1 minus cosine squared x.
So that'll be our first step.
So we're going to do
that substitution.
We'll break it into some
pieces, we'll see where we get.
OK?
So let me come over here,
and I will start the problem.
So I'm starting
with f sub n of x,
and I'm going to rewrite
it as the integral
of sine to the n minus
2 x quantity 1 minus
cosine squared x dx.
So let me take a step back.
So what did we do here?
We took two powers of
sine, and we replaced them
by what I said earlier.
We replaced them by 1
minus cosine squared x.
Right?
So this is a sine squared x.
Here I have sine x
to the n minus 2.
When multiply those together,
I get sine x to the n.
So everything's still
working out so far.
Why is this good?
Well, notice the terms we have.
Sine to the n minus 2
x dx minus the integral
of sine to the n minus
2 x cosine squared x dx.
OK.
This we like.
Why do we like this?
Because it's actually is
just like the F sub n of x,
except it has a lower power.
So this piece is actually
F sub n minus 2 of x.
So that's something we like.
Because it's already reduced
the power of sine x by 2.
So that's good.
That's part of the
reduction idea.
This one, obviously we can't
write it in terms of capital F
with some subscript.
And it maybe doesn't look so
easy to integrate right away.
But let's think about
it for a second, how
we could split this thing up.
And the goal was to use
an integration by parts.
So we're going to examine
this integral in particular.
So let me just write
that one down again here.
So we need to analyze--
I'm going to drop the minus
sign for the moment, n minus 2.
So our goal, again, is to
try and write this somehow.
Either manipulate it so it
looks like a capital F function,
or manipulate it so that
the integral sign is gone.
OK?
That's our main goal here.
So let's look at what
we can do with this.
Well, I can split this up.
What I'm going to do,
it's kind of tricky,
but what I'm going to do, is I'm
going to take all of the sine
x's, and I'm going to take
one of the cosine x's.
And I'm going to
make that one thing,
and I'm going to make the
other cosine x another thing.
And I'm going to
write them down first,
and we'll figure out
which is a good u
and which is a good v prime.
So that's going to be one thing.
And then the other
cosine x is going
to be-- does that look
like an equals sign?
Equals is going to
be the other thing.
So again, sine to
the n minus 2 x times
cosine x times cosine
x gives me what's
up here, inside the integral.
And now what I
really want to see,
I'm going to use an
integration by parts.
Well, this is easy to integrate
or take a derivative of.
But the point is that
now I can integrate this.
And why can I integrate this?
Well, I can do a
substitution on this.
So this is kind of complicated.
Because there's first,
you have to notice,
an integration by parts is
a good way to go with this.
And then you have to
see, oh my goodness,
one of the steps of integration
by parts requires substitution.
So it's a little tricky.
But I'm going to make
this, then, my v prime,
and I'm going to make this my u.
Now, I'm going to come over to
the other board to figure out,
just to make sure I
do the v prime right.
OK?
And then I'm going to
finish off this problem.
So we'll come back
here in a second.
So right now, this
is a question mark.
We're going to make sure we
do the v prime part right,
and then we're
going to write down,
this should be u*v minus
the integral of v du.
OK?
So let me give
myself some space.
So I'm trying to integrate now
sine the n minus 2 x cosine x
dx.
All right?
That's my integral
of v prime dx.
OK, so this will give me v.
Well, let's see what we do.
We're going to
now make-- I don't
want to use a u for
my substitution,
because I already
have in my mind a u.
So I'm going to let w
equal sine x, and then dw
is equal to cosine x dx.
Right?
What's the point here?
Why do we see this
as easy to integrate?
Because this is powers of sine,
and the derivative of sine
is cosine.
So that's why this lends itself
to a substitution so easily.
So that should be
fairly familiar by now,
but just to make
sure we're clear.
So then this is now the integral
of w to the n minus 2 dw.
All right?
I have sine x to the n minus 2.
So that's replaced by
w to the n minus 2.
And then dw replaces
cosine x dx.
And that is pretty easy
to integrate, I think.
That's w to the n
minus 1 over n minus 1.
I'm not going to worry
about my c's right now.
That'll come up
right at the end.
We'll put in a plus
c if we needed to.
But, so don't worry
about your plus c.
I don't want to
carry that around.
OK.
So then when I when I look at
this, what does this tell me?
This tells me that if this
is the integral of v prime,
this tells me that v is equal
to sine x to the n minus 1,
sine to the n minus
1 x, over n minus 1.
OK?
This whole bit was to help us
in the middle of the problem.
So this was the v we needed.
All right?
So let's come back, fill in
a little piece we needed,
that little gap we had,
and then we'll finish
the problem on the far right.
So let's come back.
Where was I?
OK.
So I was integrating
this quantity.
Sine to the n minus 2
x cosine squared x dx.
And I was trying to use
integration by parts.
So I had u and v prime,
and I've now calculated v,
and I know what du is.
So I'm going to write
down what this equals.
This is going to be
u, which is cosine x.
And I'll just write down v here,
so we'll see what it is again.
Times sine to the n
minus 1 x over n minus 1.
And then I have
to subtract v du.
So this is v. And what's du?
du is, or I should say, u prime
is how you saw it in class.
u prime is negative sine x.
So what am I going to get?
I'm going to get negative
sine x times the v that I had.
So when I subtract, I'm going
to end up with a plus sign.
And I'm going to
have plus, I'm going
to pull out the constant,
1 over n minus 1,
integral, now let's look at
the magic that happens here.
OK.
Let's make sure you
agree with this power.
It's the nth power of sine x.
So let's double check.
I said u was cosine x, so
u prime is negative sine x.
So I have to take u prime v.
If we come over here, we see
v is sine x to the n minus 1,
so u prime v is indeed
negative-- well, I should say,
v is the sine x to the n
minus 1 over n minus 1.
So u prime v, in fact,
has the power n on sine.
So that's maybe a little bit
complicated and nerve-racking,
but that's OK.
We're actually headed
in the right direction.
So I'm going to
rewrite the stuff
we know, and we'll see how we're
headed in the right direction.
OK.
So again, we were trying
to find F sub n of x.
And I'm going to write out
the pieces we already knew.
So we had an F sub
n minus 2 of x.
That was the first term we had.
And then we analyzed
this second piece.
And the second piece
is the one that we just
spent a little while on.
And that gave us a cosine
x sine to the n minus 1
of x over n minus 1, and
then a plus 1 over n minus 1.
And what was our thing here?
Our thing here was
F sub n of x, again.
OK.
So this might be a
little complicated.
So I'm going to show us where
all the pieces come from,
just remind us.
So we started with F
sub n of x, and I'm
claiming there are two
pieces that are of interest.
OK?
The first piece--
let's come back over.
The first piece, this
was our F sub n of x.
We wrote it this way.
The first piece was the
F sub n minus 2 of x.
Sine to the n minus 2 of x.
No problem.
Then we subtracted
this integral.
And so I spent a little
while trying to figure out
how to write that integral.
And that integral was
written right down here.
So I have to subtract
off all of that.
And the point is that this
integral here, integral
of sine x to the n, the
quantity of sine x to the n,
is F sub n of x, again.
Now you might be nervous,
because again, we just
said, we see the
same thing over-- we
see what we want to reduce
on the right-hand side.
But now all we have to
do is a little algebra.
So I'm going to come over and
show you the magic of algebra.
OK?
Let's, to make this
as easy as possible,
I'm going to erase the
parentheses here, and put
that minus sign here, so I don't
have to rewrite the whole line.
OK?
So the parentheses are gone, and
I've distributed the negative 1
to both terms.
Now notice, I want to
figure out what this is.
I'm going to figure out
what that blue thing equals.
Well, we're back to sort
of an algebra problem.
We can isolate the
blue things, and solve
for what's in the blue box.
So that's what
we're going to do.
So what do we have to do?
Well, we have to add this
to the left-hand side.
And what do we get?
Let's see what we get.
We get 1 plus 1 over n minus 1.
F sub n of x is equal to F sub
n minus 2 of x minus cosine
x sine x quantity to the
n minus 1 over n minus 1.
So all I did was I added
1 over n minus 1 times
F sub n of x to the left-hand
side-- well, to both sides,
so it moved to the
left-hand side--
and there was one of them here,
and there's 1 over n minus 1
of them here.
And let's make sure
we can simplify that.
Let's see.
We get n minus 1 over
n minus 1 plus 1.
I think it gives me
n over n minus 1.
So that gives me
I guess I'll write it again.
We're really close.
And then this whole mess again.
And now, we only
have one more step
to figure out what
F sub n of x is.
And that is to multiply both
sides by n minus 1 over n.
n minus 1 over n
multiplied here gives me 1,
and so then I get n minus 1
over n, F sub n minus 2 of x,
minus-- the n
minus 1's kill off,
and I just get cosine x sine
to the n minus 1 x over n.
So this is our answer.
Because what is the point?
Why can I say, well,
I've reduced it?
I've reduced it because
I have-- the only
integral I have is an integral
that was a power of sine x.
And that's the goal, is
that I have it in the form.
This is the power of sine
x to the n integrated.
This is sine x to the
n minus 2 integrated.
and this is just a function.
OK?
And, you know, if
we want to say,
what's the true antiderivative,
we have to allow for a plus c
here, for a true antiderivative.
But we're really interested
in this part here.
OK?
Because if we evaluate
this at bounds,
that's going to go away.
But I want to just make
sure we understand--
I think we understand the goal.
Maybe the hardest
part of this problem
is once you come over here,
was once you have these two
components.
So we did the substitution
that seems natural.
You have these two components.
This one, you should
be able to recognize,
is in the form you want.
This one is the hard
one to deal with.
But the trick is to see that
under the right splitting up
of these functions, one of
them is easy to integrate,
and one of them, you know,
it's easy to integrate or take
a derivative.
So I have a little
bit of freedom.
You don't want to
substitute back
in for cosine squared
with 1 minus sine squared,
because it will get you right
back to where you started.
You would be
substituting one way,
and then substituting
the other way.
So the goal at this
point is to sort
of-- the trick with
this one, I mean,
is this integration
by parts, which
requires some substitution.
So hopefully this was a
good exercise for you,
and you see some
of the strategies
that one needs to reduce
the powers of sine x.
You can do a very similar
type of thing with cosine x
to the n.
So if you felt like, I'm not
quite sure about this method,
you might want to try
and do something similar
with cosine x to the
n as your function
that you're integrating, and
see if you can reduce that.
And I guarantee you
can find a formula
for that in a book
or online, if you
wanted to check that answer.
So I guess this is
where I'll stop.